Amigos, África es el continente de los retos,
de los grandes retos.
Hablamos de un continente que ha comenzando
a despertar sí, pero dónde todavía está
todo por hacer:
Desarrollar una red sanitaria de verdad; impulsar
la industria, mecanizar la agricultura y por
supuesto responder al enorme reto de mejorar
la educación.
Amigos, amigas, si echamos la vista atrás,
podemos ver que si algo ha caracterizado a
los países que mayor salto económico han
logrado dar en las últimas décadas ha sido,
precisamente, su empeño por tener sistemas
educativos de mucha calidad.
En países como Japón, Corea del Sur o Singapur
la apuesta por tener sistemas educativos de
primera fue algo que facilitó su transición
económica.
En pocos años todos estos países pasaron
de ser pobres economías rudimentarias a convertirse
en potencias económicas de alto valor añadido.
Es exactamente lo mismo que ahora está ocurriendo
con China.
Por supuesto su éxito se debe a muchos factores
pero en todo ese proceso de despegue económico
la educación jugó un papel importantísimo.
Y no es solo una cuestión económica, sino
también social, cultural y política.
Y ahora, ahora le toca el turno al continente
africano.
Atentos.
(COLEGIOS QUE NO SON COLEGIOS)
Evidentemente situar al África Subsahariana
al nivel de los países desarrollados en términos
educativos será una tarea titánica que llevará
décadas.
Ahora bien, igual que una casa se empieza
por los cimientos y no por el tejado, desde
hace más 3 décadas todo tipo de organismos
públicos y privados han invertido cientos
y cientos, miles de millones de dólares en
reducir el analfabetismo y mejorar la escolarización
a lo largo y ancho de todo el África subsahariana.
Sin embargo… el reto es taaaan grande…
que aún queda mucho por hacer. Fijaos.
(La exclusión que existe en los sistemas
educativos de África es uno de los mayores
problemas. A pesar de todos los esfuerzos
realizados más del 20% de los niños de entre
6 y 11 años continúan sin ir a la escuela
y si hablamos de niños con entre 12 y 14
años, la cifra sube a 1 de cada 3.
La necesidad que hay en las regiones más
pobres de que los niños se incorporen lo
antes posible al trabajo en el campo y la
dificultad para hacer frente al coste de la
educación son las principales causas que
explican esta situación.
Y es que veréis, aunque en gran parte de
África se ha copiado el modelo de educación
pública gratuita, los padres siguen teniendo
que sufragar gastos como el uniforme, zapatos,
libros o transporte. Y, claro, eso en una
región tan pobre en ocasiones se antoja complicado.)
Pero, si pensáis que la falta de acceso
o no el poder pagar los gastos es el único
problema de la educación en África, estáis
muy pero que muy equivocados.
El otro gran reto y tal vez el reto más importante
al que se enfrenta los sistemas educativos
de África tiene que ver con la malísima
calidad docente y también con el derroche
y descontrol en el uso de los fondos públicos.
[Y sí, vale... puede que muchos de vosotros
estéis pensando, Alberto.. Es lógico que
la calidad de la educación en el África
Subsahariana no sea la más alta, ¿Qué esperas?
¿Qué tengan el nivel del MIT?]
Vale, eso está claro. Pero aquí cuando hablamos
de mala calidad nos referimos a cosas como
estas:
(En muchos países africanos como es el caso
de Sierra Leona es habitual que existan maestros
falsos, maestros que reciben su salario del
gobierno pero que ni enseñan ni trabajan.
Tan solo en Sierra Leona desde 2009 se han
detectado y eliminado más de 6.000 maestros
falsos de la nómina del Estado.)
[Aunque para ser justos, esto no es solo un
problema de África. Es un problema frecuente
en los países más pobres.
En Pakistán por ejemplo se llegaron a detectar
más de 8.000, 8.000 colegios que recibían
fondos del estado y que en realidad no existían.
Eran colegios fantasma.
[¿Qué a dónde iba el dinero? Mejor no pregunteis.]
Pero ahí no acaba todo. Incluso cuando hablamos
de maestros que existen de verdad… Bueno
digamos que en África lo de no ir a la escuela,
lo de saltarse las clases, es cosa de los
profesores y no de los alumnos. Fijaos.
(En el África subsahariana es frecuente que
los profesores no se presenten regularmente
en la escuela para trabajar. Algunos estudios
determinan que en países como Kenia o Nigeria
este absentismo afecta al 15% de toda la plantilla.
Pero si esto ya os parece una locura, atentos
porque por ejemplo en Kenya este porcentaje
aumenta hasta casi el 50, el 50% si hablamos
de profesores que van al colegio pero que
no entran a las aulas a dar clase.)
Y todo esto por no hablar de que no es algo
infrecuente que muchos maestros que sí dan
clases pues… tengan dificultades para leer
o no dominen las matemáticas básicas, incluso
aunque aunque sean profesores de matemáticas.
[Sí vamos, lo que se dice un… desastre
en toda regla.]
Y es que, no, NO basta con abrir colegios.
Así no se soluciona el problema. Hacen falta
más cosas.
Sin embargo, esperad un momento, no todo es
tan malo.
Además de los colegios públicos y los colegios
abiertos por las ONG´s y la ayuda a la cooperación,
hay otra alternativa que durante los últimos
años está ganando mucho peso en la región:
La educación privada low cost.
Sí, sí, habéis escuchado bien. Educación
privada y low cost en la misma frase.
Amigos, aunque en buena parte del mundo la
educación privada se considera reservada
a las personas con más ingresos, en África
esta barrera se está rompiendo.
[¿Podrá acaso la educación privada contribuir
a superar los problemas que tienen los sistemas
educativos del continente? Seguro que esa
pregunta nunca te la habías hecho.]
(Para profundizar más en este fenómeno y
saber que está ocurriendo, en este vídeo
nos vamos a centrar en los ejemplos de dos
países muy diferentes: Kenia y Liberia.
Kenia es una de las estrellas del despegue
africano. Su economía lleva creciendo desde
el 2013 a una media de más del 5% anual.
Liberia, en cambio, sigue siendo uno de los
10 países más pobres del mundo y está sumido
en un montón de problemas sociales y económicos.)
Pero… ¿Qué tiene que ver un país
tan pobre como Liberia con la educación privada?
¿Cómo y por qué un país con esas características
impulsaría un modelo de educación privado?
Atentos.
(LIBERIA, CONSCIENTES DEL DESASTRE)
Pues sí. El gobierno de Liberia se ha dado
cuenta de que tiene un problemón de tal dimensión
que les resulta prácticamente imposible gestionarlo
por ellos mismos.
Tras 14 años de guerra civil y constantes
epidemias, la educación ha quedado en un
segundo, tercer o cuarto plano. Y si a esto
le sumamos una corrupción descontrolada,
el fracaso de los servicios públicos está
cantado.
Y claro, de una gestión desastrosa cabe esperar
resultados también desastros.
Sin embargo, el gobierno de Liberia ha decidido
romper la baraja y apostar por una manera
bastante novedosa de lograr que los más pobres
tengan acceso a una educación mejor.
El responsable de este cambio
de estrategia ha sido ni más ni menos que
la mayor empresa dedicada a la educación
privada low cost en África: la Bridge International
Academies, una empresa fundada en el año
2008 en Kenia por dos amigos estadounidenses.
(Actualmente la Bridge cuenta con más de
600 colegios que ofrecen educación a más
de 120.000 estudiantes. Pero no es la única
empresa que se dedica a esta actividad, ni
mucho menos.
Ahí destaca también la Rising Academies,
otra de las principales empresas de colegios
privados low-cost en África, en este caso
fundada por emprendedores británicos y canadienses.)
Pero…como no podemos hablar de todas las
empresas que están surgiendo, nos vamos a
centrar en el caso de Bridge, que es la más
grande de todas.
Y la primera pregunta que tenemos que hacernos
es… ¿Cómo diantres se financia?
Pues… a día de hoy consiguen salir adelante
en gran medida con el apoyo de instituciones
como el Banco Mundial y con donaciones de
grandes empresarios como por ejemplo es el
caso de Mark Zuckerberg o Bill Gates, los
fundadores de Facebook y Microsoft.
(Y es que, hoy por hoy, en la mayor parte
de los casos, este tipo de empresas rentables,
lo que se dice rentables pues no lo son. Al
menos si no tenemos en cuenta las donaciones
que reciben.
Por ejemplo, en el caso de Bridge International,
en 2016 lograron facturar con el negocio 16
millones de dólares, pero tuvieron unas pérdidas
operativas de 12 millones. Es decir, que los
costes fueron un 75% más grandes que los
ingresos.)
Pero, un momento, no penséis que estamos
hablando de algo así como una ONG, para nada.
Estas empresas sí tienen ánimo de lucro.
Lo que ocurre es que conciben su modelo de
negocio a largo plazo. Esperan que el desarrollo
económico que se empieza a vivir en muchas
regiones de África les permita alcanzar pronto
los beneficios.
Y por supuesto, mientras tanto reciben el
apoyo de muchísimas donaciones, como las
de Bill Gates que compensan con creces todas
las pérdidas del negocio.
Ojo, son donaciones que en muchos casos reciben
precisamente por tener un plan de viabilidad.
Es decir, por esperar que sea un proyecto
rentable y por tanto autónomo y sostenible
a medio plazo.
Porque, claro, gastar es fácil pero conseguir
que un proyecto sea sostenible por sí mismo…
eso ya es otra cosa.
La cuestión es que precisamente por este
motivo, a pesar de todas esas pérdidas la
empresa continúa con su plan de expansión.
Gracias a los más de 140 millones de dólares
que ha conseguido en inversiones y donaciones.
¿Sorprendido?
El caso es que en 2016, el gobierno de Liberia,
un país donde menos del 40% de los niños
reciben educación primaria decidió colaborar
con ellos. ¿Por qué? Pues.. porque fijaos
cómo funciona la educación pública en este
país.
(“Profesores que no aparecen, incluso siendo
pagados por el Gobierno. No hay libros. La
formación es muy floja. La infraestructura
de los colegios es insegura. Tenemos que hacer
algo radical.” George Werner, ex-ministro
de educación de Liberia.)
El caso es que el acuerdo suscrito entre el
gobierno de Liberia y la Bridge International
contempla que esta empresa opere 93 colegios
públicos con más de 27.000 alumnos. El acceso
a estos colegios sigue siendo gratuito, el
gobierno paga por los estudiantes.
Se trata del mayor acuerdo firmado hasta la
fecha entre un gobierno africano y las empresas
de educación privada. Y ojo porque el experimento
parece estar siendo todo un éxito.
(En las pruebas de nivel los estudiantes de
los colegios gestionados por Bridge International
logran un resultado mucho, muchísimo mejor
que los estudiantes de los colegios operados
por el estado. Para que os hagáis una idea,
en las pruebas de nivel las diferencias son
del 100%. Es decir, los estudiantes de Bridge
logran resultados el doble mejores que los
estudiantes en colegios bajo el control del
gobierno.)
Pero… esperad un momento, porque a pesar
de todo, no todos los países le están poniendo
las cosas tan fáciles a este tipo de empresas.
Es, por ejemplo, el caso de Kenya, el país
donde nació la propia Bridge International.
Atentos.
(LA DESCONFIANZA DE KENIA)
No nos engañemos. Los colegios privados
pueden suponer toda una amenaza al control
estatal de la educación. Y eso a muchos gobiernos
no les gusta.
Y, por supuesto, a los profesores públicos
tampoco. Eso es exactamente lo que está ocurriendo
en Kenya donde el Sindicato Nacional de Profesores
lleva años realizando una durísima campaña
contra el modelo de colegios privados Low
Cost.
Supuestamente porque los profesores que imparten
clases en este tipo de centros no cuentan
con licencia gubernamental. [Aunque los resultados
académicos sean mucho mejores.]
(“Bridge no tiene autorización y es ilegal.”
Wilson Sossion, secretario general del Sindicato
Nacional Keniata de Profesores.)
Sin embargo, un momento porque sí que hay
algo de verdad en sus argumentos. La propia
empresa lo reconoce.
(“Técnicamente no cumplimos la Ley, pero
del mismo modo hay miles de colegios que están
operando de esta manera”. Shannon May, co-fundadora
de Bridge International Academies.)
Claro, entre otras cosas, los programas educativos
no están redactados en el país ni cumplen
la exigencia de los gobiernos locales, sino
no que son redactados generalmente en el extranjero.
En el caso de Bridge, el rendimiento educativo
es incluso evaluado por profesores de Harvard.
[Qué la verdad, que queréis que os diga
sin ofender, a mi por lo menos me inspiran
más confianza que los políticos de Kenia.]
(Por supuesto no todo es tan bonito. Y en
ocasiones se dan situaciones desagradables.
Empresas como Bridge International no dejan
de ser empresas con ánimo de lucro y que
exigen a los padres estar al corriente de
los pagos. Algo que en un lugar como África
no siempre es posible.)
Sin embargo, ¿Cuál es la alternativa? ¿Colegios
públicos donde los profesores van a clase
cuando les da la gana o dónde las clases
de matemáticas las imparten personas que
a duras penas saben multiplicar?
Amigos, en el África subsahariana los gobiernos
son muy ineficaces a la hora de prestar servicios
públicos. Y por eso están surgiendo muchas
alternativas. En algunos casos se trata de
empresas y en otros de organizaciones sin
ánimo de lucro.
Lo importante es que estas iniciativas están
revolucionando la educación en África.
¿Puede ser que invertir en colegios privados
low cost que esperan ganar dinero sea una
de las mejores fórmulas para contribuir a
desarrollar una educación de calidad en el
África? ¿Puede ser que la inversión sea
mejor que la mera
ayuda desinteresada?